we're looking at Boris Johnson's plane
landing back at Gatwick Airport he was
obviously in the Dominican Republic
Republic he's returning this morning
just about to touch down hang on a
second they are just about to touch down
at Gatwick should we wait for that
here we go Boris Johnson coming back
we assumed to run in the leadership race
oh they there we go a smooth Landing so
he's back
um
you you don't think that Boris Johnson
is the one to unite the Tory Brothers I
I think when you see what people are
saying out there and what big political
figures and commentators are making a
point about which is that it would be
wrong for him to come back there is
still the outstanding privileges
committee there are a whole host of
issues as to why Boris can come back we
are trying to get if those who are
supporting him are expecting a different
result they're not going to get it and I
think we've got to be absolutely clear
right now the scale of the global
economic crisis that is being faced by
so many countries around the world needs
people who've got the graph economically
to deal with the situation to be able to
ensure that we can get through this top
Theory and to me it's absolutely clear
that Rishi is the only candidate
available to be able to do this and to
get us through and to unite the party as
you asked earlier okay well we shall see
you tomorrow and thank you so much for
talking to us thank you
okay well as I was saying there Bosch
Johnson has now landed on that beer
flight back from the Dominican Republic
just touched down at Gatwick Airport
let's bring in Ali Fortescue Ali he's
back in the country but do we think he
will be back in politics
I mean I think a few days ago this
seemed quite far-fetched but you know he
there's his plane he's back in the
country allies close to him have told us
that he is up for it he wants another go
at the top job I think the big question
well there's two questions one will he
meet the threshold of 100 MPS and that
is no guarantee whatsoever I think you
know people think he will get to 60 but
beyond that will be more challenging but
if there is momentum behind him could we
see some people rowing in behind the
former prime minister
um if that looks like that's the win the
way the wind is blowing could he just
get over 100 MPS what is clear is that
Rishi sunak is at the moment the firm
favorite with MPS it looks like he has
made it onto the ballot his part his um
his campaign saying that he has more
than a hundred votes of course Rishi
sunak and Boris Johnson I think it's
fair to say there's no love lost between
these two Rishi sunak seen by many as a
person that took down Boris Johnson when
he resigned in office triggering of
course such a Javid also resigned
triggering a wave of resignations that
eventually toppled Boris Johnson's
government
um there has been some talk in some of
the papers that we could see a Johnson
sunac Alliance the two men coming
together former Rivals to bring the
party together but I've had a few
conversations with people close to both
of those men and it from the
conversations I've had you cannot see
either of them serving in the other
one's cabinet as I say you know I
haven't spoken to everyone we don't we
don't know what is going to happen
politics has been incredibly
unpredictable but it is I think hard for
many to see these two men working
together let's not forget Penny Morden
she her name has also been in the mix
she is
um got I think 19 people backing her at
the moment but there are some who worry
that she does not have the momentum
behind her at the moment and she might
not make it onto that final ballot so
will this be I think either a coronation
for Rishi sunak on Monday who is the
favorite at the moment the firm favorite
among MPS or will Boris Johnson or Penny
Morden make it on onto that final ballad